Brick by brick, we win the day for
America and our Second Amendment rights.
The United States Postal Service, that's
right, is stepping up to defend our
right to keep in bars by allowing
Americans to mail handguns for the first
time ever through the US Postal System.
That's right. All thanks to a January
2026 decision by Donald Trump's Office
of Legal Counsel. Let's put it all
together and why this is a big win for
the Second Amendment and for Americans
ability to repair and acquire handguns.
Let's talk about it when we come right
back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Bar, and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you. 2025
and 2026 Gun News Awards. All right,
exciting news. another brick in the wall
protecting our right to keep and bear
arms and all of our constitutional
liberties uh for that matter. And again,
another thank you to the Trump
administration and to the Department of
Justice thanks to an opinion from
January by the prestigious office of
legal counsel within the DOJ. As you
know, I like to use the metaphor brick
by brick by brick. We build walls. We
build precedents. And we use the
precedence we win today to build a
further edifice in favor of our second
amendment rights. That is how the game
gets played. And that's why when I say
something is major breaking news, you
may say why. It's because I understand
that is a huge brick, a building block,
a foundational block that we can go
advance our freedoms. And that occurred
in January. And now we're seeing the
fruits of that win. Specifically, in
January 2026, the prestigious Office of
Legal Council, which is the arm of the
Department of Justice that advises the
president of the United States and the
entire executive branch of what's
constitutional, what is legal, what is
not. Their opinions carry huge weight,
not just with the US Supreme Court, by
the way, but with the entire executive
branch as to what is allowed and what is
not allowed. In January of this year,
the Office of Legal Counsel came out and
we covered it on this very channel. we
covered it on this very channel came out
and said that the longstanding
law, federal statute, no less, that says
you could not mail, unless you were an
FFL and whatnot, you could not mail
handguns through the United States
postal system was unconstitutional
because it was an government action, a
state action that violated the right to
keep and bear arms and it prevented
people from mailing guns to themselves
while, for example, they were in a
second home or convocation or whatever
it was for the purposes of self-defense.
Well, I'm happy to report in light of
that January 2026 opinion from the
Office of Legal Counsel, which we'll
cover just as a reminder in a moment,
today or just now, the Postal Service,
the United States Postal Service, a
totally separate branch of government
from the DOJ, has just announced that
they have published a set of rules, new
rules and regulations that they intend
to implement. They're now looking for
comments from the public on it. And
those under those new rules and
regulations when they take effect
basically say that handguns can now be
mailed as a general matter through the
postal services. That is what they say.
So let's start with what the background
of what the what the postal service is
proposing the regulation and the rule
and then we're going to get talk about
how we got here. Here's what the postal
service has to say about their proposed
rule. Section 1715 of Title 18, United
States Code provides certain firearms
are nonmailable. Non-mailable. The
Postal Service implements section 1715
via subchapter 43. That's subchapter 43
publication 52. On January 15, 2026, the
Office of Legal Counsel, that's the OLC,
at the Department of Justice issued a
memorandum opinion for the Attorney
General concluding that section 1715 of
Title 18 US Code is unconstitutional is
unconstitutional as applied to
constitutionally protected firearms,
including handguns, because it serves an
illegitimate purpose and is inconsistent
with the nation's tradition of firearm
regulation. The Office of Legal Counsel
further concluded that the postal
service should modify its regulations to
conform with the scope of the Second
Amendment as described in the OLC
opinion. That's great background. That's
exactly what happened. The Office of
Legal Counsel said that you cannot as
the postal service discriminate against
handguns because those are
constitutionally protected items. And
yes, there's a federal statute 18 USC
1715, but the truth is it's
unconstitutional as applied to handguns
because handguns obviously are
constitutionally protected because the
US Supreme Court literally said so in
2008 in the District of Columbia versus
Heler case. So the post office goes on
and proposes the following and explains
what they're doing here. The postal
service defers to OLC's judgment as to
the lawful scope of the criminal statute
and work in consultation with OLC to
develop the proposed revisions to our
mailability regulations. Revisions to
publication 52 specify clear definitions
of mailable firearms and non-mailable
firearms consistent with the Office of
Legal Council's opinion. The proposed
revisions expand the scope of mailable
firearms compared to the existing
regulations by allowing lawful lawful
handguns to be mailed under the same
terms and conditions as lawful rifles
and shotguns. These conditions continue
to require among other things that
mailed firearms be unloaded.
Additionally, otherwise non-mailable
handguns will remain malable between
authorized persons consistent with
section 1715.
Yeah, that's a great description of
what's going on here by the postal
service. Now again, the rest of this
regulation, this proposed regulation,
which I will put a link to all this in
the description of this video, the rest
of this basically redefine certain
things. There's a whole section defining
National Firearms Act items, NFA items,
what's a machine gun, what's a shotgun,
what's an NFA item, what's a handgun,
and so on and so on with very detailed
definitions. Now, just to step back big
picture, I want to remind you how this
works.
You have statutes enacted by Congress.
Congress enacts a statute and then what
happens in many instances is the part of
the executive branch in this case the
postal service which is part of the
executive branch. The executive branch
agencies the administrative agencies are
the part of the executive branch
overseen by the president
has and often will issue what are known
as implementing regulations. And what
they basically do is in theory, at least
in theory, what they're supposed to do
is to help ordinary people understand
how the agencies are going to interpret
and apply in the real world the
congressional statutes that these
agencies are supposed to enforce and
follow the rules on. So what's just
happened here is the post office is
proposing a new set of regulations and
rules to modify their existing
regulations and rules because the office
of legal counsel that would be the super
nerdy geeky lawyers that are super
intellectuals most of whom are former
Supreme Court clerks by the way very
smart very smart uh very talented
lawyers in the office of legal counsel
very prestigious position to get okay so
very very high-end people They opine
that this statute was unconstitutional
in so far as it prevented the postal
service which is part of the government.
So the constitution applies to the
government, right? So it's part of the
government and they were basically
saying we're not going to mail handguns
under the statute. And now because of
this opinion from the office of legal
counsel which was issued during the era
Pam Bonnie is the attorney general by
the way. So we cannot say that Pam body
did nothing for the second amendment
because here's an example because the
reason why this listen carefully the
reason why this office of legal counsel
uh memorandum was written in favor of
the second amendment saying that you
should be able to mail handguns like
rifles and shotguns. That was because
the attorney general of the United
States, Pam Bondi, issued the request to
the OLC and the OLC answered the
question. And because of the answer OLC
gave in our favor in support of the
Second Amendment, now the ripple effect
of that is the post office is now going
to allow the mailing of handguns
consistent with this rule. So again, you
can see the process that plays out. Pam
Bonnie requested the opinion. The
opinion was written. The opinion is now
being relied on by the postal service to
expand our ability to mail handguns
through the mail consistent with this
regulation. You see how this process
work which is why I explain to you I
want to train you and teach you to be
the smartest person in the room to not
just understand like substantive meaning
of the second amendment in the history
of the second amendment. That's very
important but I also want you to
understand the process whereby we
actually in the real world protect all
of our constitutional freedoms. And
that's why I try to talk about the
process and the sequencing of brick by
brick by brick. Pam body makes the
request. OLC issues the opinion. It's a
good opinion and then other people rely
on the opinion to expand our freedoms.
That process is important for you to
understand because to be the smartest
person in the room, YOU GOT TO
UNDERSTAND ALL of this about American
law to fight for our right to keep and
bear arms. Now, with that said, I want
to remind you of the powerful opinion
issued by the Office of Legal Counsel
back in January, concluding that this
statute as applied by the post office
that denied the ability to mail handguns
was unconstitutional. Here's what the
head or the top of this opinion had to
say about why this statute was verboten
and violated the Second Amendment. Check
it out. The constitutionality of 18USC,
section 1715.
Section 1715 of title 18 US code is
unconstitutional as applied to
constitutionally protected firearms
including handguns because it serves an
illegitimate purpose and is inconsistent
with the nation's tradition of firearms
regulation. It goes on to say that the
department of justice may not consistent
with the constitution enforce section
1715 with respect to constitutionally
protected firearms. And then it goes on
to say, listen carefully. The postal
service should modify its regulation to
conform with this opinion dated January
15, 20126.
That's great stuff. That's a powerful
opinion. And how you notice how the OLC
flagged this issue specifically to the
postal service. Obviously, the attorneys
at the postal service got a copy of this
opinion and looked at each other and
says, "We better call up OLC and DOJ and
issue new regulations because we want to
comply with the Constitution and comply
with the law." So again, anybody who
says elections do not matter and they're
not going to vote, keep this in mind
because I can assure you it was Merrick
Garland and Joe Biden, they would not
ask OLC to issue this opinion. And if
they did ask OLC to issue this opinion,
I can assure you it would not have come
out in this way because they would have
looked for a way to throw gun owners and
the second amendment under the bus
because that's what Democrats do. C Eg
Virginia right now. Okay. Beyond that,
let's just take a look at the rationale
offered by the Office of Legal Counsel
as to why indeed this particular statute
preventing the ban mailing I should say
preventing the mailing of handguns was
unconstitutional under the Second
Amendment. Here's what the OLC had to
conclude and what they explained and
their rationale uh in their opinion in
January. Section 1715 regulates the
ability to transport, receive, and
maintain constitutionally protected
firearms which burdens the right
protected by the Second Amendment. But
section 1715's purpose and burden find
no analog in this nation's history and
tradition of firearm regulation. See
Brewan. We therefore conclude that the
statute violates the second amendment in
so far as it burdens the rights of
law-abiding citizens to ship and receive
arms in common use for lawful purposes.
Accordingly, the executive branch that
includes the DOJ and the postal service
and others may not may not consistent
with the constitution enforce section
1715 with respect to constitutionally
protected firearms and the postal
service should modify its regulations to
conform with the scope of the second
amendment as described in this opinion.
It's great stuff, right? That's exactly
right. That's how I would have analyzed
it. Maybe I would use a little bit
different language, but you know,
excellent stuff here by the Office of
Legal Counsel. Uh, we should cheer them.
And again, the real world ripple effect
is that you are now going to be able
when these regulations ultimately get
promagated. I presume you should be able
to mail handguns in a way you've been
historically able to mail shotguns and
rifles. All consistent with these
regulations and the rules. And that
again allows us to expand our right to
keep and bear arms because you can mail
books. Why can't you mail guns? Makes no
sense to me. But of course, the
anti-gunners have been at work since at
least the 1930s thanks to that terrible
president, Franklin Delaner Roosevelt,
and his equal terrible, equally terrible
attorney general, uh, which we don't
need to even mention his name, but we
can do a video on him down the road if
you really care about it. Okay, folks.
So, there you have it. Good news for the
Second Amendment out of the Postal
Service, no less. And again, thank you
to the Department of Justice for issuing
that opinion. Um, so, you know,
win-winwin. we keep on winning and
fingers crossed candles lit this trend
continues. Okay, there you have it
folks. Appreciate you tuning in. Make
sure you follow me over there on X4Box.
Don't forget to subscribe to Rumble and
YouTube. And by the way, apparently on
YouTube there's something called the
hype button, which I'm not entirely
familiar with. I haven't figured it out
or anything like that. Uh but apparently
if you're signed into your account,
you're able to hype this video and that
somehow helps me with the algorithm. So,
uh, for those of you out there that are
tech people, uh, maybe check that out
and, uh, if it makes sense to hype this
video, then please do so. I'd appreciate
it. Okay, we'll talk to you again real
soon here at, you know, where the Four
Boxes Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.